>> WNBA STAR BRITTNEY GRINER
BACK ON AMERICAN SOIL, BUT HER
FREEDOM COMING WITH A BIG COST.
THE PENTAGON FEARS THAT THE
MERCHANT OF DEATH MAY RESUME
ARMS TRAFFICKING TO TERROR
GROUPS.
BOUT PROVIDED WEAPONS, AND IT'S
SUMMED AS A DEAL WITH THE DEVIL.
HE WAS SO BAD THAT DEA AGENTS
WHO BUSTED HIM ONCE SAID THIS
VIKTOR BOUT IS ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS MEN ON THE EARTH.
HE'S A SHADOW FACILITATOR,
ARMING NOT ONLY DESIGNATED
TERRORIST GROUPS, INSURGENT
GROUPS, BUT ARMING VERY POWERFUL
DRUG TRAFFICKING CARTELS AROUND
THE GLOBE.
>> THE DEMOCRATS DON'T SEEM TOO
WORRIED.
>> WELL, HE HAS SERVED MOST OF
HIS TERM, IS MY UNDERSTANDING,
THE MAJORITY OF HIS TERM.
>> LOOK, NOBODY IS DOING
BACKFLIPS THAT HE'S A FREE MAN,
DANA.
HE WOULD HAVE BEEN FREE IN 2029.
HE WASN'T SERVING A LIFE
SENTENCE.
>> GREG?
>> GHSB.
GLAD SHE'S HOME, BUT.
THAT'S ALL YOU HAVE TO SAY.
THE DEAL SUCKS AND MAKES US WILL
GO SUCKERS.
GHSB, THAT'S ALL YOU CAN SAY,
BOTTOM LINE.
A GOOD LEADER COULD HAVE SOLVED
THIS IF OUR LEADERSHIP WAS
BLINDED BY THE IDENTITY
VARIABLES, RIGHT?
THEY LOOKED AT THE BOX OF
IDENTITY MARKERS FOR ONE PERSON,
LOOKED AT THE ONE FOR THE OTHER,
AND MADE A CHOICE.
THEY THEY DIDN'T MAKE A CHOICE,
BUT THERE'S SOME KIND OF
EVIDENCE THEY HAD MADE A CHOICE,
AND NOW THEY'RE DENYING IT.
IT'S AN INTERSECTIONAL ICON
TRUMPING A MARINE.
I'M SAY TRUMP WOULD HAVE GOTTEN
BOTH OR SAID SCREW YOU ALL, OR
NABBED A RUSSIAN ABROAD, CALLED
HIM A SPY, SAID NOW WE HAVE TWO
FOR TWO.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
AS FOR BOUT, WHAT IF HE KILLS
MORE AMERICANS, UKRAINIANS,
PEOPLE IN GENERAL?
THE TRADE, AS BAD AS IT IS, WILL
ONLY GET WORSE.
IT'S A GOOD LESSON, IF YOU'RE UP
FOR A JOB, TAKEN HOSTAGE, HOPE
YOU'RE NON-BIARY AND NOT JUST A
WHITE MALE WHO'S A MARINE.
>> JUDGE, THIS IS WHAT DRONES
ARE FOR.
>> WELL, BE INTERESTING TO SEE
THAT.
I DOUBT HE'S GOING TO DO THAT
KIND OF THING.
THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
KEEP GOING BACK TO, I SAID IT
YESTERDAY, THERE'S A REASON
RUSSIA WANTED THIS NOW.
RUSSIA IS IN THE MIDDLE OF A WAR
WITH UKRAINE.
THEY NEED VIKTOR BOUT.
RUSSIA IS FALTERING.
THE WAR IS TAKING TOO LONG.
WE HAVE THE LEVERAGE.
RUSSIA NEEDS HIS HELP.
WE COULD HAVE SAID NO.
YOU KNOW WHAT, FOR NANCY PELOSI
TO SAY, HE WOULD HAVE BEEN OUT
SOON, FIVE YEARS WITHOUT THIS
MERCHANT OF DEATH, WHO PRAYS ON
AMERICANS, KILLING AMERICANS.
EVEN SENATOR BOB MENENDEZ, A
DEMOCRATS, SAID THAT RUSSIA AND
OTHER REGIMES TAKE AMERICAN
CITIZENS HOSTAGES CANNOT PRETEND
THERE'S AN EQUIVALENCE OF
BRITTNEY GRINER IN THE WORLD AND
VIKTOR BOUT.
NOTHING CAN BE FURTHER FROM THE
TRUTH.
>> FORMER HEAD OF THE FBI'S
CRIMINAL DIVISION WORKED ON THIS
CASE, AND SAID YOU'D BE HARD TO
FIND A MAN WITH MORE BLOOD ON
HIS HANDS THAN VIKTOR BOUT.
HE WAS AN INTELLIGENCE OPERATIVE
FOR PUTIN AND RESUMES THAT
CAREER.
I CAN TELL YOU, VIKTOR BOUT
LOOKED GOOD COMING OUT OF
PRISON.
HE HAD BEEN THERE 14 YEARS?
>> YEAH.
IT'S A SHAME THAT HE'S BACK ON
THE STREETS.
IT'S ALSO A GOOD DAY FOR AMERICA
THAT AN AMERICAN PRISONER CAME
HOME FROM RUSSIA.
TO THE POINT ABOUT WHETHER WE
ONLY CARE ABOUT BLACK
BASKETBALL-PLAYING LESBIANS, JOE
BIDEN GOT TREVOR REED, A FORMER
MARINE OUT IN APRIL.
BRITTNEY GRINER WAS SITTING IN A
RUSSIAN PRISON WHEN THAT
HAPPENED AND HE GOT THE FORMER
MARINE OUT.
TREVOR REID WENT TO PRISON IN
2018.
DONALD TRUMP COULDN'T GET HIM
OUT OF PRISON.
BUT JOE BIDEN DID.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT CELEBRITY.
BECAUSE SHE'S AN INTERSECTIONAL
ICON, I'M NOT BUYING IT.
A MARINE CAME HOME BEFORE
BRITTNEY GRINER.
I'M NOT SAYING THIS GUY SHOULD
BE ON THE STREETS.
OBVIOUSLY A DIFFICULT IDEA TO
WRAP YOUR HEAD AROUND, LETTING
SOMEBODY BACK OUT THERE THAT'S
KILLED SO MANY.
>> YOU'RE NOT ADDRESSING THE
TRADE.
>> I JUST SAID IT'S A HORRIBLE
THING.
I ALSO DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU WOULD
DO.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU LEAVE
SOMEONE FOR ANOTHER NINE YEARS
IN A PENAL COLONY --
>> YOU SAY NO.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT YOU DO, YOU
READ "THE ART OF THE DEAL,"
JESSICA.
>> CHRISTMAS READING.
>> I GOT IT FOR YOU.
IT'S ALSO ON TAPE.
>> NINE COPIES.
>> THERE'S SOMEWHERE IN BETWEEN.
THEY'RE SOMEWHERE IN BETWEEN
THERE.
UKRAINE HAS TO BE THINKING, WAIT
A SECOND, JOE, SERIOUSLY GOING
TO LET THE MERCHANT OF DEATH OUT
WHILE WE'RE AT WAR WITH THESE
GUYS?
NOT HELPFUL.
I'M WONDERING HOW GRINER IS
FEELING WALKING AROUND THE
UNITED STATES RIGHT NOW.
IS HER HEAD HELD HIGH OR LOW
KNOWING THAT HER AND HER AGENT
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR SPRINGING
THE MERCHANT OF DEATH OUT THERE
IN THE WORLD.
BIDEN SAID HE DID THIS BECAUSE
HE WAS UNDER A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF PRESSURE FROM BLACK WOMEN.
REALLY?
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF PRESSURE
FROM BLACK WOMEN?
AND HE ACTS LIKE THIS.
HE'S NOT UNDER ANY PRESSURE OVER
THE BORDER.
HE'S NOT UNDER ANY PRESSURE FOR
INFLATION?
ANYTHING ELSE IN THIS RIDICULOUS
ADMINISTRATION?
HE'S UNDER PRESSURE FOR BLACK
WOMEN AND HE SPRINGS THIS
CELEBRITY OUT LIKE THAT?
>> YOU WOULD HAVE LEFT HER?
>> I'M NOT SAYING I WOULD HAVE
LEFT HER.
>> WHAT ARE YOU SAYING?
>> IF YOU HAVE SANCTIONS ON THIS
COUNTRY, WEAPONS POURING IN,
KILLING RUSSIANS, AND WE HAVE
ALL THIS OIL UNDER THE GROUND
HERE, THERE'S NOT SOMETHING WE
COULD HAVE DONE BETTER TO GET A
BETTER DEAL?
HOW ABOUT, VLAD, YOU GIVE THE
YACHT BACK.
>> WE HAVE